in this video we'll discuss and contrast
two different types of learning
discriminative and generative learning
so we'll say that a learning algorithm
corresponds to a discriminative learning
algorithm if it's trying to optimize a
conditional likelihood that is if it's
trying to optimize the last function
which looks at minus the log of the
probability of the true target given X
so for instance conditional random
fields are usually trained in a
conditional way and actually always
train conditionally because a
conditional random field only defines a
conditional distribution it actually
doesn't really look at defining a
distribution just over X or junk
distribution over Y and X another
alternative actually would be to do
generative learning that is to optimize
the joint log likelihood so in other
words optimize minus the log of the
joint probability of observing y and X
as opposed to the probability of
observing Y given that I'm observing X
so for instance hmms are usually trained
generatively so if you know about hmms
what you've probably seen is the
learning algorithm for training them
generatively though we could also train
it as the in this way because if I give
you a joint distribution over y and X I
can then do the inference of what is P
of Y given X and then I could try to
train it discriminative ly but but
initially hmm have mostly been developed
and proposed in the context of
generative training and so let's exploit
that formula a little bit so we have
that the joint distribution it can be
written down as the product of the
conditional P of Y given X times the
marginal P of X and because the log of a
sum is the sum of logs then this is also
equal to minus the log of P of Y given X
minus the log of P of X so we see that
the difference is this term here
so we have this here and this here but
we have this term that is added when
we're performing genitive learning and
so what we were thinking about this is
that perhaps this term is kind of acting
like a regularizer that is it's we're
adding another term which is does not
involve Y so it's not a term that
encourages the model to assign high
probability to the true target given X
it's just a model that requires to do
something else it's gonna favor models
that also explain well the marginal so I
assign high probability to observe any
true data so the data just the inputs
that we see from the training set and so
for that reason a good intuition is to
think that this kind of learning will
tend to fit the data better while
genitive learning will be more
regularized because of this term here
actually we can show that there are two
scenarios that we can observe in terms
of how generative versus this kind of
learning will compare ibly comparatively
come compare so if a model is well
specified so that means that the data in
our training set is that is actually was
actually generated from a model from the
same class as our model so there's a
setting of our parameters for our model
that corresponds exactly to the true
model that generated the data so if the
model is well specified then we can show
a genitive learning essentially always
better that is for any size of training
set that we use there's always going to
be a gap between what generative
learning gets in terms of generalization
performance compared to discriminative
training so genitive training is it's
going to perform better they'll they
should both eventually converge to the
two essentially an error zero so a
perfect performance but genitive
learning is going to get there much
faster however if the model is not well
specified which is
most of the time so if data was
generated by some experts that labeled
some data then this is a process that
that is almost most almost certainly
more complicated than the model we've
written down in math so so really this
is essentially for all the interesting
problem the model will tend to be will
not be well specified then the picture
is not as clear so what we'll see is a
picture that is consistent with the view
that genitive learning is just more
corresponds to more regularization so
the training set is small then we should
observe that genitive learning will get
a better performance in terms of
generalization but as we increase the
size of our training set eventually we
should reach a point where this creative
learning will catch up with genitive
learning and will start being actually
better in terms of generalization
performance to get lower generalization
error than a generative learning and in
fact more specifically what we get is
that discredit of learning will converge
to a smaller asymptotic error asymptotic
error being the error your model would
get if you had infinite amount of
training data so we'll it has a small
asymptotic error then generative
learning which won't be able to do as
well even with an infinite amount of
training data ok so again here a nice
way of so a simpler way of interpreting
this is that genitive learning means
more regularization so if there's a
small amount of training data genitive
learning will probably do better but if
I have quite a bit of training data then
now we can expect this punative learning
to eventually catch up and do better so
that's actually a good thing to know
about if you're tackling a problem for
which you either have a lot of data or
not a lot of data so you know which kind
of learning you should prefer and for
more theoretical details on this invite
you to consult this paper on this random
versus genitive classifiers so this is a
paper
enjoying and michael jordan 2001